("The Trees Above"
by Bobby Tahouri)
- [Gary] You know
I rant about Monday.
You hating it and we've
had iconic videos
about that situation.
The real question
I've been debating is
how do I tell you what to do?
Okay cool, I'll yell at you and
say if you hate your Monday then
you've got to change and
only one life this and that.
And people are like,
"Great, Mazel Tov but what I do?
"What are the steps?"
I've been thinking
a lot about it.
I think one of the biggest
steps is just to break patterns.
I was like my God, this guy was
in my farm this year and
he's gonna close
out the World Series.
Ugh, when he gave up
that hit I was like uh-oh.
I mean the rain delay was
on a whole other level.
And then all these pictures on
social media of kids that are
like predicted the Cubs in 20,
there's some kid with a yearbook
from like the 90s
like Cubs 2016,
you heard it here first.
I cannot believe the
Cubs won the World Series.
I really can't.
Need to do something, you either
need to go to some Goodwill
stores buy some stuff and post
it on eBay like
we've talked about.
You need to reach out to 5,000
people on Twitter that day that
you admire and ask them if
you can have a cup of coffee.
We've talked about that.
Some of you successfully done
that with me and Mark Cuban and
the craziest entrepreneurs
and famous people in the world.
You know, so maybe
that's what you do.
Maybe on your call out Tuesday
you go and go to six interviews
for different jobs that
you've been holding off.
Maybe on your call
out Tuesday, you know,
you go and visit your
grandmother or your dad and have
that conversation that you
needed to have whether that's
I love you or whether that's hey
I'm not gonna be pinned down by
your negativity
anymore, I'm going to do it.
Want some light?
Great.
So really fun day, got a,
DRock what you missed is we were
talking about how
great showers are.
Left this morning
4 A.M. wake-up call,
it's been a hell of a day.
Last night some of you saw
because I was pushing it
pretty hard today on social.
We had a pretty cool event where
our Budweiser commercial and our
Budweiser Facebook commercial
the way I call it video really,
really hit, big
moment for VaynerMedia.
Great moment for
our client Budweiser.
I'm super excited about it.
The AP, every sports blog, all
the industry rags just emails
that, emails from all sorts of
CMO's and marketers and former
employees so just really
trying to hit the scene.
Pretty exciting, really exciting
because we actually filmed the
behind the scenes of it so
that's good for our teams.
I don't know if we'll
be able to use it now.
If not, there's probably no
episode today unless
we use this whole narrative.
As I'm now going into
another big client thing.
Fun thing for me to
just start doing these.
I've done two or three now where
I do a wine event and
state of the union thing.
I call them vintage.
Little fun play there, right?
Little wine, little vintage
the year that you live in.
You know, marketing talk so that
should be great with
our Chase client.
We can use that too.
That's public so
couple public droppings, DRock.
- [DRock] I know.
- So I'm excited about that.
Get together with some of my
buddies afterwards and catch up
with them as I'm about to embark
on almost 2 months
in LA so pretty good.
All good stuff.
T, I don't really have a
great read on Connor McGregor.
He's obviously done a
great job building his brand.
I think he's got some
clear marketing capabilities.
So I don't have a
great, great answer for you.
I definitely don't
know him as a man.
I love the competitive spirit.
I love the showmanship.
I'd love to know
what's under the hood,
in his heart, in his soul and
then I can have a really great
read but definitely
clearly has charisma,
marketing chops to
build his brand.
Clearly a good
fighter, you know,
from what I can tell.
But I know there's a lot people
that are more educated on that.
One thing I don't think people
use enough of is Twitter
video and Snapchat.
Like if I go to my
Snapchat right now,
I'm not gonna screw with screens
but, you know, somebody
just came in here.
Thanks, Sloan.
That little move that little
camera here where you can like
do the quick little cameras.
It takes like two seconds.
Yeah, Lions and Jets are
just gonna be waiting.
Cubs inspired but we're
gonna be waiting, brother.
You know, those
three, four, five seconds,
really meaningful depth.
You know, I'm a
big, big, big, big,
big fan of Twitter video reply.
I just don't think
people use it enough.
You know, I rant about Monday
and you hating it and
we've had iconic videos.
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
About that situation,
I mean the real question
I've been debating
is how I tell you what to do?
Okay, cool, I'll yell at you and
say if you hate your Monday then
you got to change, you only
have one life this and that.
And people are like,
"Great, Mazel Tov but what I do?
"What are the steps?"
And I've been
thinking a lot about it.
I think one of the biggest
steps is just to
break patterns, right?
Like you just have
to call out tomorrow.
You have to call out Tuesday.
We have to create a
call out on Tuesday and
you need to do something.
You either need to go
to some Goodwill stores,
buy some stuff and post it on
eBay like we've talked about.
You need to reach out to 5,000
people on Twitter that day that
you admire and ask them if
you can have a cup of coffee.
We've talked about that.
Some of you successfully done
that with me and Mark Cuban and
the craziest entrepreneurs
and famous people in the world.
So maybe that's what you do.
Maybe on your call out Tuesday
you go and go to six interviews
for different jobs that
you've been holding off.
Maybe on your call
out Tuesday, you know,
you go and visit your
grandmother or your dad and have
that conversation that you
needed to have whether that's
I love you or whether that's hey
I'm not gonna be pinned down by
your negativity
anymore, I'm going to do it.
Motivation's exciting but the
practicality of an execution is
even more importantly and so
I sit here today and I make this
video and I say it's
a call out Tuesday.
Call out of work tomorrow,
I'm excited to see if anybody
calls out of VaynerMedia,
call out of work tomorrow,
do not go to school tomorrow,
do not do what you normally do
tomorrow if you
hated today's Monday,
if you hated waking up today.
If you loved the weekend.
If you can't wait for Friday
and do one of those four or five
things that I just told you or
something else that I haven't
thought of or the
reverse, or the reverse.
Why don't you take
your kids out of school?
Your kids are not going to
remember fourth-grade Tuesday
English class but taking
them somewhere just you guys,
doing something fun is something
they'll remember forever.
So that's what
I want to do this video.
I want to inspire a
call out Tuesday,
then action.
I don't want to hear that you
slept in 'til 11:30 and just
moped around and ate
some Fruity Pebbles.
Action that we just
talked or something else.
Leave a comment below with what
you're gonna do on
your call Tuesday.
Heading into Sauce for business
meeting and then have dinner
with some friends and
pretty productive day.
Just got a rant in.
Bunch of people are
gonna take off Tuesday.
(car honks)
And feeling good.
Feeling good.
Productive.
24/7/365.
("The Lovers" by VVITCH)